come back everyone we're on our house
yeah but we're still being generated on
the podcast Jenna Jillian podcast is a
different environment stop licking me
Kermit
guys you want to guess where we are it's
Las Vegas I got to excel that's right
we're here in Las Vegas right now yeah
we're at the Palms Casino and Resort
because I came here to host a pool party
tomorrow and it's relatively early in
the afternoon so it's we couldn't like
sit in traffic to leave super early
Friday morning in order to get here in
time
which was not a good idea yes we will
get really quickly
we got a sponsor this week guys yeah
episode of the Jenna and Jillian podcast
is brought to you by Squarespace
Squarespace comm is a way to build
really really awesome looking really
clean looking websites for your websites
blogs online store any any type of was
that website you're looking to build
Squarespace is the way to do it they
have 24/7 customer support which is
really key anytime you have a problem
we'll help you out they have automatic
they automatically include online stores
to any website you want to create they
have beautiful templates I mean the
design is it's just very clean looking
they work on mobile Squarespace comm for
all your website creating um how come I
don't have Squarespace for all my
website needs that sounds like a really
good plan yeah you know well and
honestly like you look at Squarespace
and some of some of the templates that
they have in some of the websites that
are actually running on squares days are
like downright beautiful like they make
it so easy to make a clean-looking
website which is it's really lost real
lost on you know it's good in a we group
when we were writing on blogs that [ __ ]
was hard to make look clean it was like
oh my god well I took a class in college
that was like C++ and that [ __ ] and what
like web programming is that design or
whatever the [ __ ] it was so hard yeah
it's not even use we'll get to it we'll
talk about it later we'll get to in the
in the middle of the podcast but thank
you Squarespace we're doing podcasts I
had a look seriously my professor used
to make us to take these like impossibly
hard pop quizzes of
that [ __ ] yeah and he like you know
they're just like a half sheet of paper
pop quiz and so I used to always write
like [ __ ] up answers cuz I wouldn't
really cuz it's so hard well yeah and we
learned this like a half an hour ago
[ __ ] I'm supposed to know this and he
would take the pop quizzes and then read
them out loud oh that's nice
and then just humiliated me he'd like so
Jenna wrote Oh blah blah blah oh that's
just wrong here super Russian and I'm
like alright you know what from now on
when I don't know an answer I'm just
gonna write like whatever the [ __ ] the
reason about the worst have you ever had
a teacher like when you had like either
essays or paragraphs where you had to be
creative and they would without saying
it's yours
they would read yours as an example and
you'd be like off [ __ ] it's mine yes no
wait and you're just like waiting till
they expose you yeah looking around and
everyone's looking around like whose is
this and I'm just oh god yeah
while I get to be creative this time
when they were gonna read it out like me
I feel like well yeah we don't have a
particular topic for this podcast but
like we're going down a [ __ ] weird
path right now that I'm down with have
you ever taken like well off the bat any
sort of creative thing where you're
surrounded by your peers and you like
constructively criticize each other and
you're in each other's work like it's
[ __ ] terrible yeah we were taking
like a creative writing class
no the clothes I mean I would say the
closest thing that I at least remember
that was to that was when I wrote for
the Chapman University newspaper and you
know the most of that is like by the
book ap style you have to do everything
right but when you did we lead columns
and you would rotate you know like
junior year I could write a column every
week but when I was just getting into it
you would have an opportunity to write a
column once in maybe two months and you
know it's a creative thing so you really
have to like not only you have to get it
approved but you have to like get
people's on your teams and on the
newspapers blessings to like write like
that or whatever you know so that was
probably the closest I came why what did
you have well I mean I took like
creative writing I think the most recent
one I think was like in high school it
took a creative writing class is like an
elective and my teacher was kind of
[ __ ] wack to begin with but like
it's super vulnerable you go through
different types of writing you [ __ ]
poetry and short stories and like all
that [ __ ] and you know you always have
like these one or two like really
pompous a-holes in your classes that
aren't giving you any sort of
constructive criticism they're just
trying to like belittle everyone else's
work yeah as like subpar yeah which is
really frustrating when they read theirs
and you're like dude that wasn't even
good well it's like and also like you
should go here because you mean
fobba-liscious well the thing that
really bugs me is like when you enter
that environment everyone is signing up
to be open and like to take criticism so
when someone takes that opportunity to
like attack you it's like really [ __ ]
up yeah what I notice about those types
of people is like they're never going to
be like oh yeah this this thing doesn't
work no that's bad they're gonna say
some condescending like backhanded
things so it's going to sound like
they're giving you criticism but really
they're just like being really rude
right yeah I mean they won't they're not
man enough to just like or woman enough
to just like step up and say where
they're thinking right they're gonna
make it sound like they're like very
esteemed and they're like giving you
help oh my god this [ __ ] yeah no it's
terrible and constructive criticism in
and of itself is a skill that you learn
which is why I think it's important that
when you're in high school or like a
younger adolescent or anything like you
learn what it's like to give someone
good criticism like helpful criticism
and what it's like to give or get you
know [ __ ] up criticism actually bro
you didn't need to say it like that yeah
but there was this one kid in my class
and he would just talk out of his
[ __ ] ass and he'd be like oh I feel
like that sentence and that story was
actually like a an analogy to Paradise
Lost and I would just like [ __ ] raise
my hand like excuse me excuse me excuse
me you're telling me the sentence you
know the Sun rose is a [ __ ] like
reference to Paradise Lost like you're
drunk go home you're talking out of your
ass and we would just sit there and have
his really heated debates because I
don't [ __ ] like when people talk out
of their ass and then he did that like
constructive criticism like backhanded
like yeah I'm so terrible yeah honestly
you know what that reminds me I was like
I remember specifically it was uh I had
ninth grade English and 11th grade
English with the same teacher cuz they
taught her name was Miss Stevens she was
a great teacher I really liked her but
there was this one and the reason why I
think I remember her is because like I
took so many classes in high school in
college namely English or literature
where I was like made to sit in the
class and just kind of listen to people
like speculate about these different
motifs and [ __ ] like just [ __ ]
I'm sorry like a lot of it was just like
reaching right and the moment I got in
there it was like AP English 11th grade
we would we would read some stuff and
someone would be like you know I really
think that this word placement you know
or this like sentence in this color of
the sky really represents the mood and I
would say I would like you know 11th
grade you're just like I'm gonna talk
now right you know I would be you know I
really I really don't think that is the
case I think they're just being literal
and then she was the only teacher who
ever made that feel like a welcome
response right it should be like you
know maybe you're right maybe it wasn't
anything right this is the most amazing
that's again that's the point of like
creative things is that it's open to
interpretation it's not always black and
white and I hate when people try to be
holier than thou and that they know what
something means and you're like nah dude
no you don't have to have an answer for
every now sometimes you just you don't
know what it means or it means nothing
it means nothing
sometimes nothing can be meant you know
I mean it's it's a great if any of you
ever watch breaking bad i know you've
watched some of it but the subreddit
like reddit.com likely imagine well it's
become this like kind of meta joke about
how every little [ __ ] thing needs
something because because there are a
lot of very cool tie-ins that Vince
Gilligan is like kind of a genius but
yeah it's like that running joke like oh
yeah that there wasn't three drops of
blood there was two because it was even
right even David last month he got cause
like no no I got it all no no yeah but
that's what I mean is really interesting
in like I don't know I feel like that
was the moment you know where I was like
okay like this is like real human being
talk like we're not just kind of under
this set of rules because in english and
literature when you're like when you're
trying to pick apart a story or
understand it like the in a sense I'm
sorry there is no wrong answer like each
person is gonna see it differently and
and when you realize that that's okay
it's like well I made it more okay in
theory there's no wrong answer although
if you have a teacher and you have to
write a like an essay yeah there are
right answers because no matter how well
you backup your argument sometimes they
just do not respect your opinion that's
true if you ever had a teacher like that
we're like okay look I mean I remember I
say this because Devon my brother yeah
um I believe wrote a fantastic paper on
why the United States should sell the
Louisiana Purchase back okay which is
you know the western half of the United
States which is a bold statement yeah
it's on the east coast yeah now it
doesn't make sense because I would be
sold back to France yeah but he wrote
this like really compelling argument but
it would like save the economy and like
do all this good just sell half of the
United States back to France and uh I
don't remember what grade he got but
that's like a perfect example of a
student being like look I'm gonna write
some [ __ ] but I'm gonna back it the
[ __ ] up yeah I mean like you better give
me an A that's true this is fantastic
yeah but a lot of teachers will be like
this is ridiculous yeah F C Unitas just
enough to like [ __ ] up your grades in
the quarter I'm a little threatened by
how well you made this sound I don't
like it yeah yeah I asked you to write a
paper on economics and how we could
improve like the economic situation you
recommend selling out the United States
dr. Frayn yeah although we did have a
bunch of teachers and when I went to
high school that like thoroughly
encouraged that type of thinking which I
think is the best like form of Education
it's just really really really pushing
you think outside of the box and think
for yourself that's it right there I was
just gonna say it's like a robot yeah
I'm like well you're told you know
you're taught to follow the rules and
everything it is very important to like
encourage that muscle in your brain that
let you know maybe I can think
differently than kind of everyone in the
room
so yeah I know that because you you know
like half of the essay papers that's why
they give you like you can pick from
topics or like you have to eat your
topic approved in the beginning yeah
because you know that your teacher gets
75 [ __ ] papers all in the same thing
and they're just like flipping through
them like mailing it in ya be B minus B
plus ya they write like one little hash
mark like on one page and like yeah I
guess so
B mmm mail it in yeah um we're gonna
take a really quick break and then we'll
be back in a second cuz we've got a
different camera we have to take a break
take a break man you got a sponsor
get her back carry bag hey Chi I like
you so much better when you sit on my
chair and you're not running around I
love it when you don't run around and
round and round anyway guys thank you
for hanging on and watching this episode
of the gentleman podcast we wanna talk
to you really quick about Squarespace
I'm John exciting sponsor this podcast
is sponsored by Squarespace comso Thank
You Squarespace you know what I was
saying before you've had extensive
experience working on blogs I've had a
reasonable amount experience they're the
same thing
and you know when we were doing it it
was in a completely different time you'd
either be on someone else's website or
you'd be creating your own blog which is
a task even in itself just to keep it
running let it make it look any sort of
sexy yeah okay MySpace code was about
enough for me yeah and then anything
passed and it wouldn't Sparkle and it
said it was supposed to Sparkle and
there and you absolutely needed to learn
how to code to some degree to make now
it is completely changed and Squarespace
is the epitome of why that is the case
Squarespace is able to build you some
really really beautiful websites if you
want a website like I said an online
store even a blog they will help you
create they have a bunch of different
templates they have amazing customer
support around the clock and one thing I
think is really cool is that not only is
every every website you build comes with
an online store or whatever but it works
on all different platforms you have an
iPad you have it Google Apple TV you
have an iPhone
there's mobile platforms there's mobile
versions
sit down in the right way so that's
ridiculous how frustrating is it when
you're on a website and then you want
mobile and you're just like what is it
there's like half the features
completely different websites let it go
on every day I'm like can you just shell
out some cash and yeah like complete a
mobile version of your website or just
get some Squarespace damn it
Squarespace is able to use a cover page
feature where they'll allow you to have
a beautiful looking website in one page
it's not like you know it's not like you
have to keep scrolling through look
Squarespace is is a great you know
website builder so check out Squarespace
if you want to build a website there is
a free trial you don't even have to use
your credit card you can get started and
start building your website if you do
decide you want to keep Squarespace you
can get 10% off by entering the product
code Jay Jay Jay Jay Jay at the checkout
um but yes squarespace.com to check that
out thank you again Squarespace for
sponsoring space of the general just
while we're on that topic yeah um I like
how that kind of dictated where we were
going for the spot well true cool ah if
you run a small business and you don't
have a website can you please use our
free trial personal space because it's
really frustrating
like what do you go on Yelp to like a
you know we're looking for a wig or some
food or some whatever and a restaurant
or a business or wake up yeah anybody
doesn't have a website it's really
really really frustrating not correct
there's no excuse if you can get a free
trial come on bro yeah I mean you're
gonna get the thing ten billion times
more business if you have a [ __ ]
website you can't not have a website I
mean and that's the thing like you know
when this has happened to me on certain
cases when I'm looking like namely on
like SoundCloud so like if I'm looking
for music for my videos because I like
to find it for music to use in my blogs
and sometimes I'll find you know a cool
soundcloud artist and then I go to their
website and either it's like a
completely shitty like this guy why is
even bother and then it's like the other
half the coin is like wow this guy has
maybe 3000 followers on soundcloud but
his website looks like jay-z's website
like it looks [ __ ] clean right
there's good colors great pictures it
flows well nothing's in the way
everything's where you need it right and
you're like this is this is this is what
I need this is what I need as a consumer
and this is what I
he does is a business owner right on the
website I can't tell you how many
people's well let me just put it this
way so the other day I was looking for a
party bus so then we go to your show
a bunch of us are going to Julian show
in Irvine yeah at the shadow to her and
I you know was looking for different
party bus services and I clicked on
someone's you know whatever name and it
took me to their Facebook page yeah get
the [ __ ] out of my face how do you
really expect anyone to book your
business to poke them through Facebook
could poke down one but it's a joke like
I think they only had one party bus so
clearly it's you know somebody trying to
get on their feet and gets really
quickly though did you go with them no
okay I sort of make sure cuz I know the
one you went with it didn't even have
they were like oh we have this luxury
trolley shaped but those are just words
I know and in all their pictures just of
like this couple like at a pumpkin patch
you know people who start random wedding
in their trolley I think I think that
that goes along with the theme of like
certain businesses just don't want to
learn and grow with the times and they
suffer so badly because I see websites
like that you see [ __ ] businesses who
conduct themselves like they're in 1990
right we'll do a few honestly the only
exception to the rule is like a small
little mom-and-pop like sushi place
where they all they do is take phone
orders like because they just can't
[ __ ] handle it no absolute is so bomb
that no one cares absolutely I mean
those like the hole in the wall and
they're they've been surviving and they
will continue to survive on pure quality
but the only problem is everyone that
owns a restaurant thinks their food is
really bomb and no one cares yeah yeah
that's true I mean I and think about
this like I discovered Denny's to it
have you seen Danny's Twitter account
dude I mean like I don't like Denny's I
don't really eat breakfast food out ever
unless I'm like hammered and it's like
7:00 a.m. oh it's like Alicia's I can't
have pancakes oh it's just eggs and
bacon to me but anyway like I saw I
think a tweet says look at the flick of
the grits and I was like done I'm
following Denny's I like Denny's it's
like that
that moment where you feel like they
somehow in some way get you as a
consumer they get you as a human being
on the internet right it's like they
make the effort to find not just a
social media correspondent who's going
to tweet for you but someone who
literally is in that world right so they
can relate they can tweet
things that are funny like I said I
don't even not even a huge fan of
Jenny's I don't have anything against
them but I'm just not a particular fan
of them and I follow them on Twitter why
would that ever happen unless they're
doing something really right right I
mean it's the opposite of these
old-school businesses who aren't even
like trying you know what I mean I know
it seems like a blatant like sort of
oversight to be like oh you know it's
kind of a lot of work and we don't know
how to do it like it's really not hard
to find some just ask a
thirteen-year-old yeah hey what can we
do you ask your kids CEO of Denny's you
know what I mean like they clearly
figured it out it's not a big deal and
you know I bet a lot of these like the
restaurants and places that don't like
they the people that work there don't
really speak great English yeah they
probably have kids and grandkids that
speak great English they totally help
them yep yep you're on but it seems like
such a shame that instead of trying to
embrace it like there's no harm really
that's gonna come from embracing your
online business absolutely it can only
do you good
right but what does it say earlier what
was incredibly frustrating about
people's websites is when you go to
someone's website it all it has is just
a link to their Facebook Twitter
Instagram I'm like no no I want to go to
your website and have an experience what
the [ __ ] is this I do that a lot like
when I'm doing research for the g15 the
real show yeah and you know all these
musicians like all they have because you
have to do stocking alert yeah or else
you have nothing today and I'm like okay
all I have is your Facebook page right
now yeah like please what the hell man
and then if you go to your website it's
just like your most current video yeah
and then just links to all your social
like you have no like about section or
like warning or schedule or like where I
can buy tickets to see you like it's
just such like a missed opportunity you
know I mean yeah I really I was on a
website the other day and I was like
okay I want to find their social Twitter
their Twitter their entry I want to find
it well how do I find something scroll
it up and down the top the bottom I
don't see anything it's finally go to
contact and at the bottom of the contact
page they have the icons the Twitter the
Instagram YouTube whatever so I was like
alright [ __ ] it let's see what their
Twitter is how many phones I got
whatever I click on the Twitter button
and it redirects me to a window where it
tweets for me and then
hashtags their company no one tagged I
don't even know what their social is
anymore still no and it's like Kirk
trying to create a tweet for me with
this lame-ass hashtag that no one's
gonna [ __ ] if you don't have a
Twitter account or one available on your
own damn website
why am I supposed to help you with a
hashtag how's that gonna help you it's
like beyond me no I just like it's also
a little bit confusing I know like
hairdressers makeup artist like a lot of
their business they get through like
instagrams stuff like that because it's
a visual business yeah for sure but then
I feel like a lot of them think that it
wouldn't help them to have a website
because then they're like oh I just you
know sift through my DMS all day every
day and like you know what if you had a
professional-looking like web site then
you would probably get a lot more
business just from online searches not
from just like hash tag braids hash tag
updo hash tag Los Angeles absolutely and
I'm not even a [ __ ] line at some
point in the near future I'm gonna need
a website you know I mean I feel like
it's not to that point we're in business
exactly you know anything like I don't
have a business per se or a company per
se at this moment but I feel like at a
certain point in the near future I'm
gonna benefit greatly from having
website and when I'm looking around
something like Squarespace it's like I
mean how can you how first of all it's
like you have you have to really have
lived in the age before now online to
appreciate what Squarespace is very
another take my god like you remember
[ __ ] like WordPress and [ __ ] all
those shits that like I know is white
right no matter how many hours you put
in to like one blog post you could not
make it look sexy it was like shitty
tile you couldn't change the font barely
like any at all you had like the
crappiest ads on the side that you got
sense for I mean oh my god so it's like
gives you engage just it's a huge huge
amazing thing that we're living in a
world where anyone can [ __ ] him on a
computer be like oh hey mom who's 45
years older than me look at this amazing
looking website that you like right I
just built like in my room that you can
do though you didn't - you knew - you
know how you make that really good
pudding Stu Donuts mom whatever yeah
[ __ ]
squirts crazy she goes like putting see
mom as a blog you remember Sabu hog yeah
she's always had a blog it's called
Helen hallway net I think I don't know
about your mom's yeah it's really cute
like she just write some nice little
like your mom's and they she's always
she's had it for years and she updates
it regularly that makes perfect sense
she's one of the most with it people on
Twitter every age I've ever ever they're
not like long thoughts there's not like
a chick tana pictures it's not like
autobiographical or anything for her
pleasure really doesn't she was right
takes some certain thoughts or she'll
treat you like put a link in there so
yeah she was talking about like my
mother is in her 60s I won't say how old
she is but like if she can figure it out
what the [ __ ] is everybody else's Excuse
man you know I mean they just like don't
want to they're lazy and voice or it's
honestly it's the rent I feel like he
goes hand in hand that's threatened and
the you know not valuing what online
presence brings to the table I think so
you know half of its like yeah like we
can exist without all that online
[ __ ] all that Twitter stupid like
you know scoffing at the online power of
what websites and social can do but the
other half is like just like you know
kind of presenting and and just like we
can do without it
right and then you live in a
neighborhood and you watch businesses
turn over and over and over because they
can't even get the locals to go and you
know like how hard is it to get local
like it I'm sorry if a restaurant is not
on like [ __ ] grub hub or eat24 or
whatever near us they don't exist to me
yeah you know I mean if you're not in my
general area and you don't deliver
towards me because you don't have an
online delivery service yeah like those
restaurants don't need drivers and stuff
GrubHub literally supplies the drivers
they need to sign it they need to sign
up and take online orders and just make
the food I mean yeah we were in like
sprinkles the other day right and there
was like two GrubHub guys waiting for
their orders and I'm like dude my
wrinkles like they are yeah cupcakes
like yeah like you really have to have a
giant amazing reason that I could never
imagine
I've grabbed a baby but there's there's
I've seen restaurants around us yeah
that don't they never show up on GrubHub
when we search for food yeah so they
don't exist to me yeah we only seen when
we drive by might as well just be a
business building or whatever why would
I ever like find a parking spot and walk
in there and go well maybe it's a little
bit difficult and they don't want to
cater the consumer they want to cater
their lazy workers right well it's nice
in a place where you get foot traffic
you get people that come into your
restaurant or like if you're near a lot
of businesses or something yeah but not
in the [ __ ] middle of Suburbia are
people gonna come into your restaurant
yeah you know we're sure they're just
gonna [ __ ] ignore it yeah I don't
know I'm honestly curious to hear what
you guys have to say about this and like
you know with your experiences you know
I I like to think that we have a mix of
wages in this audience for the podcast
yeah I have a lot of people my age and a
little older come up to me tell me they
like the podcast which is really cool to
me right so I really want to hear you
guys chime in on like what your thoughts
are on how different businesses choose
whether or not to put effort into online
like and you know like in a couple years
are they gonna even have that choice
right well that's the thing when you're
running a business yeah and you might be
going under and you're like all right we
you know in theory we have enough money
to survive for another year and a half
and if we don't start making some
serious profits yeah then we're gonna go
under you know it's just sort of
basically I think it's gonna be taking
some more and more seriously and so they
they see it as like oh well why am I
gonna tack on another expense that
that's gonna put us under even faster
instead of realizing like well if your
inevitable death is coming at the rate
that you're going making an investment
to open yourself up to a new market yeah
it's not like investing in a new logo
it's not paying money to get new tires
on your delivery truck like this is
gonna go long long distance for you this
investment right but people don't see it
that I don't but and like I said in the
future I feel like they're gonna either
see it that way or be done right away
I mean we're gonna we're living in an
increasingly digital world like you
can't just neglect it anymore right I
just like I can't get over how
frustrating it is when someone doesn't
even have a website
no it's imperiex me like I don't want to
call makes me wanna not give them
business out of spite like [ __ ] you I
don't want to give you
business.you unique effort I know it's
also because we're like so we're from
the [ __ ] Information Age basically
we're unless you can click click click
and then learn everything that you need
to know immediately yeah I don't really
want to call you and have you explain
something to me
why would we do that when we have an
option that of your competitor to just
click click and do we want right I just
want to see what kind of food you have
or I just want to see what kind of
[ __ ] nails you do
yeah or hair you do or clothes you have
absolutely honestly like it's very
simple let us know what you guys think
of all this right yeah um and I love
that the the fact that we are sponsored
by Squarespace this week's part this
discussion I know we were gonna stay
here and talk about what we were doing
yeah which is way more boring than what
we're talking about because we're just
doing it up in Vegas we're gonna have a
pool party tomorrow but yes thank you so
much Squarespace for your support of the
identity and podcast check out
squarespace.com to build your own
website beautiful templates 24/7
customer support online store given to
you free trial you only need a credit
card but if you do enter the product
code JJ for Jenna and Julian at checkout
you'll get 10% off of your website yeah
and thank you to the people that watch
and listen to the podcast for being
receptive to us having sponsors and we
try and do a good job to make sure that
they're people that align with us thank
you for letting us do that because it
keeps your podcast alive and left
exactly so thank you guys for letting us
do that and thank you for people that
sponsor us Thank You Squarespace and
thank you for listening your [ __ ] hat
yeah how come you said it better thank
you guys we'll see you next week
Vegas we're gonna go be tired in Vegas
very tired I was definitely too